maybe we can revisit zoli's brain for a
moment because I think it's a very
common thing I think creative people are
very passionate and they have all these
ideas and maybe they over commit to them
I know I've done it so what do you think
it was that hindered you from finishing
it you know I was in college I'd done
very well with my shorts in ecology
c---berkeley but you know spike lee had
just made do the right thing with this
credit card and i graduated i thought
i'm gonna make a feature I written the
script causal his brain but it required
like 40 locations 200 actors it was just
way too ambitious for I had just learned
how to make movies and I was taking on
this way too ambitious project for 22
year old straight up a college but you
know I was young and look at all the 22
I had so many 22 year old interns and
they're just full of vibrato they think
they can do anything which is fantastic
until life kicks you in the stomach and
I you know kept running out of money I
was holding down three jobs I was a
waitress I was professor's assistant I
was secretary to doctor's office and I
was trying to do this and I would I got
investors from friends and family and I
was just too ambitious of a project and
eventually Iran Iran money on a number
of occasions but you know I really
learned i think to this day I learned
how to be a good boss through that
because all these people would show up
and they work for me for free you know
it was an independent film well you
better make it really fun and
interesting if you want hundreds of
people to show up for free every weekend
to shoot an independent film so I think
it really taught me to really think
about how if their people were enjoying
themselves and I learned you know I no
longer go to family and friends actually
for for funding because that it when the
film storm I started running out of
money which of course I got then I would
get I kind of fall into a couple
depressions over running out of money
and it was such a bad spiral and when
everything was tied into that I also
didn't want to see family and friends
who had invested and it was this
horrible spiral for me so I realized I
really needed to separate that in my
life that was something else which i do
now for my
films so you know everyone's got their
own stuff but I really learned a lot
from that experience and someday I'm
going to finish that fella I've been
thinking it's at my film studio now and
we're organizing it it's all on film
16-millimeter there's tons of footage so
but obviously i'm not going to reshoot
anything now so i'm thinking about
turning it into a short but i learned a
lot from that and I listen I gave a lot
of talks where I use that as my central
what did I learn what have I learned and
not experience so feeling is good it's
how you learn I think resumes would be a
lot more interesting if people put what
they fail that and what did you learn
from that I do that as an interview
question I don't know ask was your
biggest failure in would you learn we
could reels a lot
you